à des points importants de ce livre
c'est que comme vous venez de le dire
c'est que c'est la baisse du niveau de
vie que vous feriez chez la grande
majorité des français pratiquement à
parler 1% on va dire tout le monde
aurez vous verrez son niveau de vie
baisser or c'est le contraire de ce que
nous dit lindsay depuis très longtemps
et vous l'expliquez vous expliquer
pourquoi
notamment parce que l'insee
sous-estiment totalement l'importance du
logement le prix du logement en france a
été multiplié par cent cinquante pour
cent vingt ans il a triplé à paris et
dans les calculs de l'insee ça compte
pourquoi 6% à peu près voilà c'est ça il
donc forcément il ya d'autres il ya
d'autres il ya d'autres artifices comme
le jeu sur les indices de qualité donc
c'est le prix d'un produit augmente on
dit bill et de meilleure qualité donc on
ne tient pas compte de ça de dire de
l'augmentation
il faut savoir que comme si la qualité
augmente on se dit bon ben il n'a pas
augmenté en prit puisque il a augmenté
au qualité voilà donc mais j'ai repris
le
un livre sur le sujet du camp et
j'ajoute quand même à ce livre que dans
l'évaluation de la baisse du niveau de
vie et là on parle des biens qui sont
produits pour le marché et acheter sur
le marché et donc on utilise un indice
des prix etc
en fait dans la baisse du niveau de vie
il faut intégrer la dégradation des
services publics c'est à dire que y'a un
le ce dont tout le monde est conscient
les services hospitaliers si on ne
remplace pas les infirmières on ne
remplace pas les médecins et les gens
vivre des conditions je dirais de plus
en plus dans les hôpitaux
voilà c'est une baisse du niveau de vie
et à ce sens je suis passé j'ai fait ce
que j'ai fait c'est très bizarre de dire
ça pour la france ce que j'avais fait en
1976 pour lui aux soviétiques
je l'aï regardé la mortalité infantile
qui remontent les chefs des petites
remontée et puis avant la france était
l'un des pays leaders avec les
scandinaves où les japonais c'est un
truc on a perdu c'est c'est très
sensible
[Musique]